650 heures de travail artisanal pour ce
meuble destiné à un client américain
une pièce en métal pesant près d'une
tonne on a une structure merck et en
tubes et après c'est des habillages avec
beaucoup de fer plat beaucoup de tôles
découpées laser qui sont au fond vissé
avec davis bombay plus à docteur
l'entreprise dunod mallié participe à la
sauvegarde de cette activité artisanale
la ferronnerie d'art un savoir-faire
basée sur la maîtrise du fer et de la
métallerie fille créé en 1995 cette
société comptabilise 15 salariés dont
deux dessinateurs un chef d'atelier et
des ouvriers de production
on fabrique des pièces uniques on
fabrique des rampes d'escalier un petit
peu atypique avec ce que ça c'est le
coeur du métier quand même ce qu'on
appelle le débardage quelque chose
d'assez qui est en voie de disparition
pour le coup tous les métaux sont mis à
contribution pour des rampes d'escalier
classique jusqu'à des projets
exceptionnels
c'est le cas pour un client russe au
total il a fallu dix mille heures de
travail
cette trempe là qu'on a fait à moscou
j'en parle tout le temps parce que ça
une pièce exceptionnelle de ferronnerie
après des projets fous là on fait des
portes en cuivre pour qu'ils vont partir
en australie
ça reste très artisanal il n'y a pas en
fait nous on n'a pas de plus value sur
l'achat matière sûr c'est pas là où où
la rentabilité de l'entreprise se fait
c'est vraiment sur le taux horaire est
la revente d'un savoir-faire donc du
coup on passe énormément de temps sur
les pièces en centaines d'heures chaque
pièce des centaines d'heures dunod
mallié mise sur la ferronnerie du luxe
son chiffre d'affaires près d'un million
cinq cent mille euros avec une
progression de 10% par an sur ces cinq
dernières années 70 % de l'activité se
fait à l'export pour trouver de la main
d'oeuvre la société pioche dans les
réseaux des compagnons du tour de france
beaucoup de jeunes conforme en interne
après bien sûr le réseau des compagnons
parce que c'est quand même une école
entre guillemets une école
d'excellence alors après l'évolution du
métier je la connais pas trop quoi c'est
des choses des sujets auxquels je pense
de temps en temps c'est à dire est ce
que dans 20 ans on aura encore besoin
dans un d'un sérum il ne s'est pas
encore métier rare la ferronnerie d'art
aurait de l'avenir malgré la mutation
industrielle dans les yvelines d'après
midi mallié ils sont moins de cinq
ateliers spécialisés dans cette activité
[Musique]